today is very tough tomorrow is more
tougher
the day of tomorrow is beautiful but
most people die tomorrow evening
you have to work very hard every tough
days
every tough situations problems you meet
that is the training of yourself
[Music]
after 18 years we grow from
18 people to today close to 60
000 people it is
really not easy
but we survived today
we are one of the
biggest internet companies in the world
i think we are lucky
we made so many mistakes but we still
survive
how can you be continued to be lucky
that is the question keep on asking me
the day when i choose the name alibaba
alibaba is not a chinese name it's a
arabic name it's the name from alibaba
1001 mistakes
or alibaba 1001 nights the story
i have a lot of terrible experience
made a lot of mistakes when i was
young and child
i think if you succeed
every mistakes become a legendary if you
feel
that's just a garbage you know what i'm
saying
i think everybody
has great stories
everybody has a lot of mistakes
everybody have a lot of problems but
very few people
listen to you one day when you become
successful
people listen to you say wow
you're great i'm not that great
i was born in a normal family
and i'm not good at schooling
course i tried to study hard but as a
boy you know
my school was not that good at that time
so
i failed looking for jobs looking for
joining university joining good schools
but i never give up
and i think there's one thing i learned
is that um why
why you should have a chance to be
successful
everybody should get used to be get used
to
fail but not get used to be
accepted by other people why other
people should help you
you should earn the right to be helped
so the thing i learned
is that don't give up my
opportunity has not come yet when
everybody complained that is the
opportunity
i always thought when i was young when i
was graduating
in the high school or university i
thought bill gates took up
my job you know bill gates did all the
successful things
larry erisson from oracle they
they took all the wonderful
opportunities ibm
benefit we people have no opportunity
and i think i aim too high i should
aim to support and help
the people around me do tiny things
i never thought i could be today
after 18 years alibaba become today's
size
not because i'm smart i don't think i'm
a smart person
but i have i work with a lot of smart
people and most
smart people they always want to do
successful things
quick easy things and
i think it's not easy to be successful
quickly every time everything we do we
prepare for 10 years
i know i'm not smart if we want to be
successful
we have to win 10 years later if we want
to be successful
we have to work with
smart people if we want to be successful
we should make a lot of mistakes and
never give up
a lot of people they make mistake their
problem they give up
we never give up we learn from the
mistakes
and i think when we feel the message
the experience that i want to give you a
device i want to give you
you will judge when this person will be
successful not
by when he feel he thinks it's
his fault or the other thought if he
thinks
my fear because of the others this guy
has no chance
those people who fail always think
it is my fault i cannot do it properly i
should change care i change it there
these guys have opportunities so i
learn a lot from those
people who fail i learned a lot from
those people who made mistakes
i learned a lot from my mistakes so
this is my life attitude when i feel i
say
see i will fail when i succeed i say
well
i never know i could be successful
[Music]
this makes me very positive and
optimistic
and because of so many mistakes
too much failure that makes me never
complain
because i get used to that we are making
mistake every day even to today
we made stupid decisions
almost every day nobody knows
we thought it's smart but finally proves
stupid
but we learn we do again
we learn we do again that's the way
that's the life attitude
you